en el vídeo anterior vimos cómo calcular
un punto de intersección y que se
encuentra sobre el plano de un triángulo
pero cómo saber si el punto es como este
que está dentro del triángulo o bien
como este que se encuentra fuera del
triángulo
de hecho el método que utiliza nuestro
rey tracer hace uso del álgebra
vectorial pero un método que es
básicamente el mismo es fácil de
explicar si entendemos lo que son los
promedios ponderados
observa que conforme cambio los pesos en
el promedio el punto de intersección y
se mueve
y si todos los pesos son positivos y
estará dentro del triángulo
pero observa lo que ocurre cuando uno o
más pesos son negativos y se escapa del
triángulo lotería si podemos determinar
los pesos necesarios para producir y
podemos simplemente checar sus signos si
uno o dos de ellos son negativos y
estará fuera del triángulo de lo
contrario y se encontrará en el interior
pero como podemos determinar los pesos
tejemos dos como incógnitas por el
momento y llamemos dos a minúscula de
minúscula y se minúscula cada punto y en
el plano de a mayúscula b mayúscula y c
mayúscula puede escribirse como un
promedio ponderado de a mayúscula b
mayúscula y pse mayúscula
si selecciono valores de a minúscula de
minúscula y c minúscula de manera que su
suma sea igual a 1 me puedo olvidar del
denominador
la ecuación resultante y es igual a
minúscula por a mayúscula y minúscula
por b mayúscula más e minúscula porsche
mayúscula y representa las siguientes
tres ecuaciones una para la coordenada x
una para la coordenada ye y otra para la
zeta
conocemos los valores de i a mayúscula b
mayúscula y se mayúscula así que las
únicas incógnitas son a minúscula b
minúscula y c minúscula entonces esto se
trata de tres ecuaciones y tres
incógnitas que pueden solucionarse para
encontrar los valores de la minúscula de
minúscula y se minúscula una vez que
sepas cuánto valen a minúscula d
minúscula y c minúscula checa su signo
para determinar si se encuentra dentro
del triángulo en este último ejercicio
se te pedirá calcular los puntos de
intersección y y determinar si están
dentro o fuera del triángulo
ahora después de todo esto adelante
escribe tu propio rey tracer